moi je pense que les professeurs ils
sont là pour éduquer les enfants et leur
apprendre des choses pas la peine de les
menacer je pense mais la plupart des
parents l'amo grande majorité des
parents trappe fonte ou par leurs
enfants soient bien éduqué dans la
bienveillance depuis quelques jours les
habitants de trappes découvre une
nouvelle fois que leur commune fait la
une des médias nationaux la raison cet
article publié vendredi soir par nos
confrères du point
et qui donne la parole à didier lemaire
professeur de philosophie au lycée de la
plaine de neauphle depuis une vingtaine
d'années didier lemaire il fait part de
ses inquiétudes évoque un
communautarisme religieux de plus en
plus présent une emprise islamistes
forte qui ne lui permettent plus
d'exercer sa profession dans le respect
des principes républicains
aujourd'hui il ya des atteintes à la
laïcité qui ne sont pas simplement des
actes individuels mais vraiment des
actes de pressions répétées collective
par exemple en début d'année dans une
classe des élèves
l'ensemble des filles de la classe qui
refusent une sortie scolaire au prétexte
qu'elles seront filmés sans leur sens
leur voile donc c'est cette
transformation finalement à l'intérieur
même de l'école qui qui qui hantent qui
empiète sur notre notre liberté
pédagogique placé depuis quelques
semaines sous protection policière
didier lemaire serait la cible de
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux après
une première prise de parole dans les
médias au lendemain de l'assassinât du
professeur semelle pâtit une lettre
ouverte publiée dans l'ope ce qu'ils
avaient interpellé au delà de nos
frontières
en témoigne ce reportage d'une
télévision néerlandaise et on ne peut
que s'interroger aujourd'hui sur
l'avenir de notre métier
comment enseigner les langues les arts
les sciences la culture générale
à des enfants qui sont soumis dès leur
plus jeune âge à la pression sociale
phénoménale de ces idéologues alors que
la loi contre le séparatisme est à
l'étude à l'assemblée nationale ces
déclarations largement fait réagir dans
les rangs politiques à commencer par le
député de la circonscription
je pense à tous les trois de la
république qui doivent aussi subir des
menaces et et rencontré de grosses
difficultés dans leur dans leur métier
et c'est pour ça que nous dans la loi
dite de séparatistes à l'assemblée
nationale avec le groupe l'est
républicain on veut renforcer cette loi
pour pouvoir protéger davantage protéger
davantage les enseignants et puis je
voudrais vous dire aussi que j'aimerais
qu'un jour dans les médias on puisse
parler en bien de trappes et pas
toujours gagner un problème maire de
trappes en attente de son recours auprès
du conseil d'état après l'invalidation
de son élection ali rabais estime que
malgré tout certaines déclarations de
didier lemaire sont infondées je défends
le droit et la liberté d'expression de
tout le monde y compris de didier
lemaire et y compris pour raconter des
insanités d'accord je lui refuse le
droit de me diffamer c'est pour ça que
j'irai dans les tribunaux mais je
l'autorisent à raconter ce qu'il veut y
compris des mensonges y compris qu'il
n'y a pas de café ouvert aux femmes y
compris qu'il n'y a pas de coiffeur
ouvert aux femmes on a le droit dans ce
pays de raconter ce que l'on souhaite
une vision sans doute partagé par les
acteurs sur le terrain de plusieurs
associations mais qui ne pourraient
masquer ce chiffre 67 jeune originaire
de trappes sont partis en irak ou en
syrie entre 2014 et 2016